benim seni çıkaracağım Çabuk o kadar
okullar YouTube'un en büyük coğrafi
kanalına Hepiniz hoş geldiniz 39'un Evet
teyze joyful kampımızın bugün geldik 33
gününe aynı zamanda
15 günü Dur bakalım bundan önceki bütün
dersleri bırak Neden bugün geldik nüfusa
nüfus en önemli konulardan bir tanesi
doğal afet 1 sırada nüfus 2 sırada ve o
kadar şanslısın ki en kolay konular
bunlar Sadece yorum yapmayı
öğreniyorsunuz nüfus konusunda bütün her
şeyi bir kenara bırakıp bütün enerjinin
nüfusa vereceksin anlaştık mı Evet bugün
nüfusu öğreneceğiz size bir var tam
derse girmeden önce benim de elime geldi
poster notlarımız 1-1,5 senedir böyle
bir şey planlıyordum Siz böyle tam
masada çalışırken duvarınızı asmalık
haritalarınız yoktu ve ben böyle
eksiklikleri hiçbir zaman kaçırmam Çünkü
ben de asmak istiyordum ama böyle poster
harita tarzında bir şey yoktu ve bu
haritaları sonunda yap şu şekilde
gençler bakın şöyle duvara
asabiliyorsunuz Bu haritalar Bayağı kötü
görünüyor şöyle böyle çevirip çevirip
duvara asabiliyorsunuz renkli renkli ben
çok beğendim ben çok beni çok hoşuma
gitti şöyle netlemiyor ha şöyle canlı
canlı net bir şekilde masanızın
karşısındaki duvarı böyle artık dilsiz
haritalarda doldurup annenizden azar
yemenize gerek yok Böyle çeviri çeviri
tek bir posterle bütün hepsinden
kurtulabilirsiniz şöyle dünya haritaları
var içerisinde Tabii en önemlileri var
içerisinde
bir ülke haritalarımız var şöyle şöyle
de Türkiye haritalarımız var buradan
mesela Dağlar arka taraf daha farklılar
burada ovalar bu şekilde gidiyor Burada
mesela bitkiler gibi bu şekilde gidiyor
İnşallah çok güzel olacağını düşünüyorum
her evde sadece lise Bu ders için değil
bu zaten gençler orada dursun güzel bir
şekilde inceleyin diye yani bir atlas
gibi duvardaki atlas gibi her eve
girecek inşallah ileride evleri
dolaşırken bunları sürekli göreceğim
Evet bu arada Posteri nereye koyayım
düşündüm biraz Siz tabii buradaki
haritayı görmüyorsunuz Ah buraya ne
kadar güzel bir harita yaptım sırf
açıdan dolayı gösteremiyorum size derste
ya şortum göründü şöyle duruyor açıdan
dolayı gösteremiyorum size Neyse iki
yere asma ihtimalim var Şuraya mı asayım
yoksa Şuraya mı asayım sizin
önerilerinizi bekliyorum sanki şurası
daha ideal gibi değil mi şurası falan
daha ideal gibi mi ya da şuraya sizin
önerilerinizi bekliyorum Evet hemen
hazırlanmış öyle Kalem aldım Ben hazırım
sen de hazırsan beğen tuşuna
hazırlandıysan O zaman ne diyoruz yoksa
şöyle bir defa öğren bir daha asla
unutma gençlersin canım
geldik sadece yorumlamayı öğreneceksin
ezberleyecek hiçbir şey yok senin alt
dallarını öğretirken sana ne
göstermiştim haftalarında nüfusu
görürken orada bir demografik kavramı
göstermiştim sana demografiyi bilmen
lazım çıkar testlerde karşına demografi
Demokrasiyi çağrıştırıyordu nüfusuyordu
Demokrasiyi nüfuslar yapar ha hocam bu
nüfus bilme nüfusu inceleyen bilimdir
diyeceksin bu sayınınlarına Bakalım
şimdi
gidiyoruz nasıl sayılıyordu şimdi nasıl
sayılıyor şimdi nasıl sayılıyor biliyor
musun haberim bile Neden Çünkü otomatik
sistemde sayılıyor adrese dayalı nüfus
kayıt sistemiyle sayılıyor şu an hepimiz
adrese kayıtlı mıyız Evet otomatik
olarak zamanı geldiğinde bir tuşa
basılarak bütün istatistikler ortaya
dökülebiliyor ve otomatik Bir sayım var
TÜİK yapıyor Bunu adrese dayalı nüfus
sayım sistemi diyoruz biz buna yani şu
dejur dejure diyoruz biz buna dejur diye
okunuyor diğeri DeFacto DeFacto yüz yüze
geçmişte nasıldı Ben çocukken
hatırlıyorum ikinci üçüncü sınıflarda
olabilirim köydeydik o zaman köyde
öğretmen geliyordu
geliyordu şöyle bizi güzel bir şekilde
sayıyordu Ondan sonra gidiyordu yüz yüze
sayıyordu bizi işte yüz yüze geçmişte
yapılan Bu yüz yüze nüfus sayımına
DeFacto diyoruz ben Edebi ise almayı
internetten yapamıyorum gençler Çünkü
internetten yaptığın zaman üstünde
olacak mı olmayacak mı yok bilmem geri
yolla pek bana Uyan şeyler değil o
yüzden gidip
100-150'si almayı elbise almayı da
DeFacto DeFacto'ya gidiyoruz elbiseleri
nasıl alıyorum Orada yüz yüze Demek ki
birisi bize DeFacto derse hocam
DeFacto'da yüz yüze elbise alıyorduk yüz
yüze yapılan nüfus sayımı diğeri de
değişiyor da otomatik adrese dayalı
yapılan nüfus sayımı olmuş oluyor
buradaki mantığa oturttuk bu Tamam
geldik şimdi şuraya şimdi dünyada bu
nüfus sayımın mantığını ilk yapanlar
kimler kimler Sümerler mısırlar çok mu
önemli O kadar önemli değil Bizim
Osmanlı'da Kim yapmış bunu İkinci Mahmut
yapmış buna Ne diyorduk Biz Kel Mahmut
diyorduk değil mi Kel Mahmut geliyordu
sınıfa sınıftakileri sayıyordu böyle
nüfusu sayıyordu Kim kaçmış sigara
içmeye kaçan kim var diyorduk Kel Mahmut
2 Mahmut ilk sayımları yapmış bizde bu
osmanlı'dakiler ama böyle modern anlamda
yapılan sayımları yapanlarda İskandinav
ülkeleri iskandinavdan kastımız ne
Norveç İsveç Finlandiya Danimarka bu
şekilde oradaki ülkeleri yapmışlar ilk
modern'lar bunlar çok mu önemli O kadar
önemli değil
Burası bilmen lazım bizim ülkemizde
gençler 1927 yılında yapılabiliyor nüfus
sayımları savaştan çıkmışız biraz zaman
geçiyor ondan sonra nüfus sayımları
yapılıyor burada asıl bilmen gereken şu
hemen şurası bak geçmişte nüfus
sayımlarının yapılma amacı nedir Bize
sorulduğunda genelde bu soruluyor
geçmişte şu anki amaçla nüfus sayımları
yapılmıyor şu an biz kadın erkek
nüfusunu tespit ediyoruz birçok şeyi
tespit ediyoruz nüfus sayımlarında ama
geçmişte amaç bu değildi geçmişte
çıkacak soruda Bu bir vergi toplaması
lazım oradaki imparatorlukların
Devletleri o vergiyi ne kadar
toplayacağını bilmesi lazım nüfusu
bilinmesi lazım Bunun için o yüzden
vergi miktarını belirlemek
istiyorlar
ve sınır belirlemek için yani o dönem
için en önemli şey ne Bir vergi diğeri
asker Aslında en önemlisi asker sonra
vergi asker askeri belirleyebilmek için
de asker alacaklar Çünkü oradaki nüfusu
tespit etmeleri lazım bir asker için
yapıyoruz oradaki sayımı 2 vergi
miktarını belirlemek için bize çıkarsa
bu çıkardı orada şu ana kadar
öğrendiklerimiz de
nüfusun cinsiyetine bakacağız yaşına
bakacağız bunlar bize bir ülke hakkında
ne kadar yorum yapma yeteneği kazandırır
bunu öğrenmen lazım Mesela ben bir
ülke yapısına bakarsam o ülke hakkında
nasıl bir yorum yapabilir cinsiyet
yapısından kastımız ne kadın ve
erkeklerin nüfus miktarından ne kadar
oranları var bu
var yapabilirsin bunu çıkartman lazım
Mesela ben bir Ülkesi ülkeye baktım x
ülkesine baktım Bu x ülkesinde kadınlar
fazla He ülkesine baktım Burada da
erkekler fazla
üşüyor muyum ben
gelişmemiş ayrımını yapman lazım ya
kadın
lar erkekler çok fazlaysa bu ülke
gelişmemiştir böyle bir yorum yapabilir
misin böyle bir yorum yapamaz kadınların
ve erkeklerin oranı sana o ülkenin
gelişmiş mi gelişmemiş olduğunu
göstermez mantıken düşün nasıl nasıl
gösterirsin şunu gösterebilir Ama mesela
bir yerde eğer ki o yer göç veren bir
yerse Mesela bizim Doğu tarafları göç
veren yerler Van'da görev yaparken ben
orada mesela kadın nüfusu
orada bir van'dakiler ki daha çok inşaat
sektöründe çalışıyorlar erkekler
erkeklerde gidiyorlar göç veren yerler
Tabii mevsimlik olabilir bu göç veriyor
sonuçta orası erkekler gidiyorlar
çalışıyorlar kadın o bölgede daha fazla
olmuş oluyor güç alan yer İstanbullu
düşünün daha fazla erkek göçü almış
oluyor Daha fazla göç aldığı içinde
erkek nüfusu daha fazla olabiliyor
buradaki mantığı sadece sorulursa sana
unutma Tamam peki
hocam ama yaşam süresine bakacağım Bu
ülkenin Yani bu ülkede insanlar ortalama
kaç yaşına kadar yaşayabiliyorlar bu
bana bu ülkede gelişmiş mi gelişmemiş mi
diye bir yorum yaptırabilir mi
yaptırabilir en model örneğini alalım
Japonya İsviçre japonya'dayız insanlar
çok fazla yaşıyorlar çok fazla
yaşamalarının nedeni ne sağlık imkanları
iyi Japonya'da sağlık imkanları iyi
Ekonomi iyi bütün bunları düşündüğünüz
zaman ölümler az bütün bunları
düşündüğün zaman ortalama yaşam süresi
artıyor değil mi ortalama yaşam süresi
Japonya gibi ülkelerde fazla O zaman
şunu söyleyebilir miyiz hocam ortalama
yaşam süresinin fazla olduğu ülkeler
gelişmiş ülkelerdir bakın
Japonya'da ortalama yaşam süresi genel
kısımda kadın erkek diye ayırmayalım
Bunu genel kısımda 84 84 yaşına kadar
yaşayabiliyorlar İsviçre'de 83 Güney
Kore'de 83 sinek burada 83 İspanya'da
yaşıyorlarsa Biz de ne diyoruz hocam
diyoruz Bunlar gelişmiş bir ülkedir diye
yorum yapabiliyoruz ama gelin bakın
buraya Somali 56 yaş Çat 59 yaş insanlar
Burada çok fazla yaşayamıyor O zaman
şunu söyleyebiliyoruz bu ülkeye
gelişmemiştir şimdi gelişmemiştir
kavramı aslında yanlış bir kavram yani
Türkiye gelişmemiştir Hani incitmeyelim
onları diye
az gelişmiştir demek daha mantıklı
oluyor yani gelişmemiştir diye
duyacaksınızdır ağzımda ama
gelişmemiştir çok doğru bir tabir değil
az gelişmiştir desek daha doğru olur
anlaştık mı Mesela Tamam o zaman ne
gördük ortalama yaşam süresi fazlaysa
bir ülkede Japonya gibi o ülke
gelişmiştir ortalama yaşam süresi
düşükse o ülke az gelişmiştir yorumunu
yapabildik mi yaptık bakın Çat ve
Somali'nin bulunduğu yeri de buraya
koyduk Ara ara böyle ülkeler geçtikçe
harita çalışması da yapıp onu da o
konunun içerisinde yedirip haritadaki
ülkelerin de genel ülkelerinde en önemli
çıkma ihtimali olan ülkeleri de görmüş
oluyoruz Somali bakın Afrika'nın boynuzu
boynuzu gibi orada çatla daha içkisinde
kalıyor Evet geldik Nüfusun yaş
gruplarına dağılışına yani çocuk nüfusu
ne kadar yaşlının nüfusu ne kadar ya da
hocam çocuk nüfusu ne ya şimdi nüfusu ne
bu bizim işi yok der bakın
0-14 yaş arasındaysan sen ve Mesela bu
yaş arasında değilim ama sen 0-14 yaş
arasındaysan çocuk olarak geçiyorsun ama
sen 14'ün üstüne geçtiğinde artık sen
15-64 yaş arasındaysan yetişkin aktif
nüfusu olarak geçiyorsun sen büyük bir
ihtimalle şu an 14 yaştan fazlasın beni
izliyorsan büyük bir ihtimalle 14 yaşı
geçmişsindir sen artık yetişkin Aktif
nüfus içerisindesin Sen evet
bakın Tutmayın çocuk nüfusa sorularda bu
çok çıkacak karşımıza Bağımlı nüfus
denir yani çocuk nüfus bir bağımlıdır
değil mi herhangi bir çalışma vesaire
yapıyor mu hayır bize bağımlı değil mi
yani evdeki Artık kim bakıyorsa ya da
devlete bağımlıdır ama nasıl bağımlı
çocuk Bağımlı nüfus bunu gelişmiş ya da
gelişmemiş ülkelerle nasıl
bağdaştırabiliriz şöyle düşünün az
gelişmiş ülkelerde somalide çok fazla
çocuk vardır Çok fazla doğum vardır Çok
fazla doğum çocuk olduğu için Somali
gibi az gelişmiş ülkelerde çocuk Bağımlı
nüfus oranı fazladır böyle bir yorum çık
isteyecek senden sorularda bu yorumu da
koyduk mu kenara Tamam sen şu an hangi
yaş grubundasın yetişkin aktif yaş
grubundasın Ben de şu an kaç yaşındayım
Sizce ben de şu an böyle Tabii ki 25
falan diyorsunuz ama değil tabii ki 32
yaşındayım ben de burada artık yetişkin
Aktif nüfus içerisindeyim dikkat edin
Bir de 65 yaş var burada 65'in üstü
şimdi bu da yaşlı nüfus yaşlı nüfus O da
bağımlı değil mi emekli olduklarını
düşünün yani şu nüfus çalışıyor mu aktif
mi Hayır vahşili nüfustu aslında bir
bağımlı nüfusludur yaşlı bağımlı
nüfus ederse bana şimdi şöyle düşünün
Somali'de yaşlı Bağımlı nüfus fazla olur
mu orada yaşlı Bağımlı nüfus fazla değil
yaşlı bağımlı nüfusun fazla olduğu ülke
derse bize hocam He burası gelişmiş bir
ülke diyeceksin Japonya mesela yaşlı
bağımlı yaşlıları çok fazla yaşlı
Bağımlı nüfus çok fazla bu yorumu
yapabilmen lazımdı burada Anlaştık mı
buraya kadar tamam okur yazar oranı
hakkında ne söyleyebiliriz hocam
gelişmiş ülkelerde okur yazar oranı
fazladır az gelişmiş Somali gibi
ülkelerde okur yazar oranı azdır Burada
yine bir çalışmamız var Andora andora'da
ne hocam Hemen öğrenin şurada bakın
Fransa ile İspanya arasında Şuradaki bir
ülke andorayı da Bu dersle beraber Belki
ilk defa duymuşsunuz şöyle bir haritayı
açıp bir bakın bakalım Portekiz İspanya
Fransa şurası Atlas Okyanusu şurası
Akdeniz Evet burada harita çalışmamızda
yapmış olduk ha okuryazar oranına bakın
andorofillandiya Vatikan gibi böyle
gelişmiş ülkelerde %
100 Tabii Angora Vatikan gibi ülkelerde
daha küçük az nüf
usları çıkması mantıklı Finlandiya'nın
eğitim sisteminde biliyoruz Zaten
hepimiz ama Afganistan gibi ülkelere
bakın Afganistan'a bakar mısınız %28
okumaya yazma oranı bayağı düşük Evet
geldik hocam Peki doğum ve ölüm
oranlarıyla alakalı nasıl bir
gelişmişlik yorum yapabiliriz ülkelerin
nüfusunda şimdi
ülkelerden gidelim az gelişmiş
ülkelerden kastımız ne Nijerya Bakın bu
sefer daha farklı ülkeler koyduk buraya
Nijerya şurada bak Görüyor musunuz
ortalama doğum
ları bunların doğum nüfusu artış hızları
çok fazla bakın Kenya bu kısımda kalıyor
mali bu kısımda kalıyor Bu gibi
ülkelerde ölüm ve doğum oranları
fazladır yani doğum fazla ama ölüm de
fazla yani bir ülkede doğumlar ve
ölümler fazlaysa o ülke için az
gelişmiştir Diyebiliriz ama Japonya gibi
bir ülkedeyiz kimi burada neyi örnek
vermişiz İspanya'ya örnek vermişiz
İspanya gibi bir ülkedeyiz gelişmiş bir
ülke o zaman doğum ve ölüm oranları az
olacak İspanya gibi ülkelerde doğumlar
çok fazla
olma çok yapmaz doğumlar az ölümler
sağlık var ortalama yaşam fazla o zaman
ölümler de ağzı burada
ölümler gelişmiş
ülkeler yorumunu
yorumlamayı öğreniyorsun burada senin ne
öğrenmen lazımdı biliyor musun O
maddelerin hiçbir tanesini ezberlememen
lazım
Bunları sadece şunu bilmen lazım
yorumlayabilmeyi öğreniyoruz yani şu
hocam bir ülkede doğumlar çok fazla He o
zaman şunu diyeceksin Hocam doğum çok
fazlaysa çok çocuk yapıyorlar gelişmemiş
ülke diyeceksin bu yorumu yapıyorsan bu
işte bu dersin ana noktası Burası Evet
geldik Bunun dışında yapmamız gereken
bir yorum daha var şehir ve kır nüfus
Yani bir ülkede insanlar gelişmiş ülkeye
düşünelim yine ben hep gelişmiş ülkeye
gençler Almanya ve Somali örneği veririm
gelişmiş ülkeyi Almanya gelişmiyor az
gelişmiş ülkeye Somali bunu her zaman
her soruyu çözerken de veririm kafamda
çok rahatlıkla somutlamış olurum
somutlayın mesela almanya'dayız
Almanya'da Kırı nüfusumu fazla olur
şehir nüfusu mu daha çok şehirde Yaşar
insanlar değil mi gelişmiş ülkelerde
insanlar şehirdedir ama az gelişmiş
Somali gibi ülkelerde insanlar daha çok
Kırsal alanda yaşarlar bu yorumu da
öğrendik mi Tamam burada Portekizce
Kenya örneği verilmiş mesela bunun
dışında aktif
mi faktörleri dağılımı bu sene değil
yani 2023'te 2022'de böyle bir
soru bekliyoruz sanayi sektörü tarım
sektörü ile alakalı yine ayrıca
öğreneceğiz ama şurada şunu bilmen
yeterli bizim için nüfus kısmında bakın
birinci ekonomik sektör tarımdır
birincilde kastımız ilk yapılmaya
başlayan gibi düşün tarımdan sonra
Sanayi geldi ha O zaman ona ikinci
ekonomik sektör diyelim sanayiden sonra
üçüncü ekonomik sektör sektör geldi
hizmet geldi sonra 4-5 geliyor O diğer
konu burada bunu bilmeye yeterli bir
tarım Sanayi izle bir ülkede İnsanların
çoğu tarımda çalışıyorsa O ülkeye Eyvah
Eyvah çünkü Eğer ülkede insanlar tarımda
çalışıyorsa o ülke büyük bir ihtimalle
az gelişmiş bir ülke yorumu yapıyoruz
ama bir ülkede insanlar hizmette
çalışıyorsa o ülke gelişmiştir ülke
yorumu yapıyoruz gelişmiş ülkelerde
insanlar hizmet sektöründe yani üçüncü
ekonomik sektörde çalışır ama az
gelişmiş Somali gibi ülkelerde insanlar
yani ne kadar Sanayi var ne kadar hizmet
var oralarda çok fazla çalışamıyor
nerede tarımda çalışıyor daha çok bunu
lütfen unutmuyorsun bu niçin çok çok
önemli Şu tarafa bakın Norveç İsveç
Finlandiya kutbaya yakın ülkeler Bunlar
ve çok gelişmiş ülkelerdir Burayı da
unutma Bu da yine bir harita çalışması
olarak kalsın Şimdi geldik nüfus
artışına Nüfus artışı kısmında güzel bir
yorumu öğreneceksin şimdi bu yorumu iyi
öğrenmeni istiyorum senden çünkü
sorularda çok fazla karşına çıkacak Ve
senin kafanı çok karıştıracak bakın bir
ülkede nüfus artış hızı farklı bir
şeydir nüfusu miktarı farklı bir şeydir
bunu sana bir sonraki sayfalardaki bir
grafikten anlatacağım sayfa
164'ü açmanı istiyorum senden şöyle
sayfa 164 şimdi nüfus artış hızı farklı
bir şey nüfus miktarı farklı bir şey ne
demek hocam Şu arkadaki sütunlar
nüfus miktarını gösteriyor Şuradaki çiz
ginin hızını gösteriyor nüfusun ne kadar
hızlı artıp ne kadar yavaş arttığını
gösteriyor şimdi bakın Gençler bu ülkede
Şu ülkenin nüfusu bu ülkede nüfus artış
hızına Bak şurada
1985'te bir dönem fazlaymış görüyor
musunuz sonra 1945'te bir şey olmuş
40-45'te nüfus artış hızı azalmış bakın
nüfus azalmamış dikkat edin nüfusun
artma hızı azalmış nedir bu mesela önce
de nüfus 21 kişi artarken Tabi bu milyon
kişi üzerinden düşürdüğünüzde bindi
olarak veriliyor bu ama biz bunu sanki
21 kişi artıyormuş gibi düşünelim daha
iyi oturması için mesela önceden 21 kişi
artıyormuş sonra kaç kişi artmış 10 kişi
artmış nüfus artış hızı düşmüş nüfusu
yine artmış mı yine artmış Yani şöyle
düşünün bunu önceden diyelim ki 100
burada 21 kişi daha geldi kaç olduk 121
olduğumuz varsayalım Tabii ki böyle
değil de böyle olduğunu düşünelim 121
olduk Sonra
nüfus 10 kişi daha olduğunu varsayalım
131 kişi oldu bak nüfus artış hızı
düşmüş önceden 20 artıyormuş sonra 10
artmış ama yine artmış mı yine Art
mış uzun miktarı yine de artmış dikkat
edin Şimdi nüfus artış hızına bak nüfus
artış hızı bazen düşmüş bazen artmış
bazen düşmüş bazen artmış bazen düşmüş
bazen düşmüş sonra bundan sonra tekrar
2020'de koronadan sonra tekrar artıyor
Bütün bunlar artış azalır nüfus artış
hızında gerçekleşiyor ama nüfusun
miktarına bakın nüfusun miktarı sürekli
olarak artmış Nüfusun miktarını ne zaman
azalır bu grafikte Şuradaki nüfus artış
hızı azalır
ama düşme var mı Yok o zaman buradan
nüfusun miktarı Her zaman artış
gösterecek burada düşen ne burada düşen
nüfus artış hızı düşüyor Peki hocam
böyle bir grafik
te olduğu neresidir nüfus miktarının en
az olduğu yılı soruyorum sana mantıken
düşünürsen en başı olur Çünkü nüfus
buradan başlamış bundan sonra sürekli
artmış mı sürekli artmış Peki nüfusun
miktarının en fazla olduğu Yıl neresi ve
hocam nüfus grafiğinin en son yılı olur
Çünkü oraya kadar hep artmış nüfus Bazen
azaltmış yani Bazen bu artış az olmuş
ama yine de artmış Bazen fazla olmuş ama
yine de artmış bazen az olmuş 5 kişiye
düşmüş ama yine de artmış yani o zaman
nüfusun en fazla olduğu yıl grafiğin en
sonundaki yıl olmuş oluyor ama burada
sıfırın altına düşmüş olsaydı sıfırın
altına düştüğünün bir önceki sütununu o
zaman söylerdi buradaki mantığı kaçırma
ama tamam sıfırın altına düşmeyecek
sıfırın altında düşersin nüfus miktarı
azalmış olur Peki hocam bu grafikte
nüfus artış hızının en az olduğu yer
neresi nüfus artış hızı diyor bana o
zaman gelirim nüfus artış hızı çizgisine
bakarım en az olduğu yıl 2020 nüfusu
artış hızının en fazla olduğu Yıl neresi
şurada 28'li olan kısım olur yani
1960'lı yıllar olur buradaki mantığı
nüfus artış hız grafiğinin nasıl
yorumlandığını Anladık mı Evet geçelim
dersimize tamam mı Şuradaki bilgilerin
hepsini ben aktardım sana şimdi gördüm
geldik buraya Nüfus artışında ikiye
ayırıyoruz Biz bunu çok basit bak çok
basit doğal Nüfus artışı gerçek nüfus
artış doğal Nüfus artışı dediğinde sana
şunu düşüneceksin doğal doğum mu bak
doğumumu çağrıştırıyor nüf Arkadaşlar
iki şekilde artış gösteriyor bir doğal
nüfus artış yani şu doğumlar var ölümler
var Doğanlar 5 kişi
5 Kişi doğdu 3 tane de ölüm olmuş 5 Kişi
doğdu 3 tanesi ölürse şöyle 3 artı
demişim 3 tanesi ölürse bu ülke iki kişi
artar yani şu 5 Kişi doğdu 3 tanesi öldü
ülke 2 kişi arttı işte doğumlar ve
ölümler
arası farktan ortaya çıkan nüfusa doğal
Nüfus artışı diyoruz aklımıza nasıl
gelecek doğal Nüfus artışı doğumlar ha
hocam doğumlar ve ölümlerden kaynaklanan
nüfusu artışı bu diyeceksin Tamam diğeri
gerçek nüfusu artışı gerçek Nüfus artışı
göç diyeceksin bana gerçek göç Ha şu
hocam doğumlar ve ölümler var Tamam ama
bir de işin içerisinde göç olması lazım
Çünkü sen bir ülkeye baktın Ben şimdi bu
ülkeye baktım hocam 5 kişi doğmuş 3 kişi
ölmüş Normalde 2 kişi artması lazım bu
ülkenin ama ülkeye bir bakıyorum ülke 12
kişi artmış gerçekte gerçekte gerçekte
göçte almış demek ki gerçekte 12 kişi
atmış Hocam diyorum o zaman bu ülke On
kişi fazladan bir şey var burada Demek
ki dışarıdan göç almış diyorum sana
böyle sorular da sorulabilir böyle der
ki sana İşte bu ülkenin doğal Nüfus
artışı iki iken gerçek nüfusu artışı
12'dir ne oldu bu ülkede diye sorar göç
almış dersin şöyle sorsam sana bu ülk
gerçek nüfusa doğal Nüfus artışı ikiyken
ülkeye bir bakıyoruz ülke bir kişi
artmış Nerede bu Bir kişi eksik hocam
dışarıya göç vermiş bu ülke diye bir
yorum yapabilirsin o zaman değil mi
gerçek Nüfus artışında O zaman ben
gerçek nüfusu artışında işin içerisine
göçüde katmış oluyor Tamam mıyız buraya
kadar Tamam şimdi
olduğu ülkedir Çünkü çok ciddi doğumlar
var burada özellikle doğal Nüfus artışı
Burada çok fazla doğal nüfus artış hızı
ne demek doğal doğumlar ve ölümlerden
kaynaklanan burada doğumlar çok fazla
burada Mesela gerçek nüfusu artışı çok
fazla olmaz Neden Çünkü gerçek nüfusta
göçler de olacak bu Afrika ülkeleri
gerçek yani göç veriyor dışarıya göç
almıyor gerçek Nüfus artışı nerede fazla
olur gerçek nüfusu artışı biraz daha
böyle Avrupa gibi ülkelerde göç
aldıkları için orada gerçek nüfusu
artışının olduğunu görüyoruz tamam bir
de gençler şunu unutmayın bazı ülkeler
Hani sıfırın altına grafik düşer
demiştim ya size sıfırın altına düşerse
grafik nüfus azalır diye bazı ülkelerde
sıfırın altında grafik düşebiliyor bu
daha çok Rusya Küba gibi ülkelerde
Japonya'da da gerçekleşebiliyor bu nüfus
arttı eksi yazıyor sıfırın altına
düşüyor özellikle Rusya bu gibi
ülkelerde Aile kavramı gitmiş oluyor
sağlıksız beslenme alkol tüketimi Bunlar
da etkili olabiliyor bir de İşin garip
bir kısmı var bakın -20 lerde eksi
40'larda nüfus artış hızının olduğu
kısımlar var burada çok istisnai bir
durum var Venezuella ve Suriye gibi
ülkeler şimdi Suriye gibi ülkeleri
düşünün bu o ilk savaş yaşandığı için
Suriye'de şu an biz bunu çok Yakından
tanıyoruz ülkemizde çok ciddi bir
mülteci göçü var Suriye'de Suriye'de
nüfus çok ciddi anlamda azalmış oluyor
savaşlar salgın hastalıklar bu gibi
durabiliyorlar ve o durumda çok ciddi
bir eksiği yazma durumu oluyor nüfusun o
ülkelerde Suriye'de böyle bir durum var
venez
nüfusu arttıran faktörler nüfusu azaltan
faktörleri yani ne oluyor da bir ülkede
nüfus artıyor bir doğum oranlarının
fazla olması bunu yorumlayabiliriz ben
hocam bir ülkedeyim doğum oranlarım
fazla olursa E o zaman nüfusu artar bunu
mantığı kolay diğeri sağlık
hizmetlerinin gelişmesi şimdi bunların
yorumlarını öğreteceğim Ben sana burada
sen nasıl yorumlanacağını öğreniyorsun
bu manı kırarım Bu maddeleri
ezberlemeyeceksin öğretmenlerimiz bazen
dinliyorlar videolarımı lütfen hocalarım
Eğer öğrencilerinize siz bu maddeleri
nüfus arttıran faktörler diye ezber
olarak madde madde sorarsanız böyle bir
soru mantığıyla sorarsanız öğrenciler de
ezberlemek zorunda kalır öğrenciyi
ezbereği dersiniz ve burada Coğrafyadan
nefret etmelerine Coğrafyadan hiçbir şey
kazanmamalarına neden olur lütfen böyle
bir soru mantığıyla çocuklara ezbere
etmeyelim çocuklara böyle soru
sormamamız gerekir bizim nasıl sormamız
gerekir sağlık hizmetlerinin gelişmesi
nüfusu arttıran faktör müdür azaltan
faktör müdür tarzında yorum yapmasını
istememiz lazım Sen de öğrenirken şimdi
sağlık hizmetlerini arttırırsam nüfus
azalır mı artar mı Bunun yorumunu
yapmayı öğren Ben bir yerde sağlığı
arttırırsam E ne olacak insanlar
ölmeyecekler insanlar ölmeyince de nüfus
artmış olacak yapman gereken Yorum bu
bir diğeri ülkelerin nüfusu arttırıcı
politikaları bu 11 sınıf konusu mesela
bazı ülkelerin nüfusunu arttırmaya
çalışır bazı ülkelerin nüfusunu
azaltmaya çalışır nüfus artış hızını
azaltmaya çalışır nedir bunlar mesela
Almanya gibi bir ülkedeyiz çocukluk
ortada çalıştıracak kimse yok o zaman
nüfusunu arttırmaya çalışırsın nüfusun
arttırmaya çalışırsan da nüfus
artacaktır bu daha nüfusu arttıran
faktörlerden bir tanesi ülkelerin
uyguladığı Politikalar iş imkanlarının
artması da nüfusun artmasını sağlar
Nasıl yani hocam iş imkanı artınca nüfus
mu artıyor şöyle oluyor gençler iş
imkanı artınca ekonomi iyileşiyor
ekonomi var para var Yani para varsa da
insanlar çocuk yapmaktan o kadar fazla
Korkmazlar ama paranın olmaması
durumunda insanlar işte 3 tane
yapacağına bir tane yapıyor gibi bir
durum var iş imkanları artarsa Ekonomi
iyi olursa artış Hızı da artacaktır yani
gelenekler gelenekler de etkili Bunda
nasıl hepimizin geleneği nasıl çocuk
yapacağız üzerine
kurulu böyle kabul
ediniz çocukluğumuzdan beri bunu aşılar
büyüyeceksin okuyacaksın işini eline
alacaksın işte askere gideceksin
geleceksin vesaire Ondan sonra
evleneceksin evlendikten sonra da çocuk
yapacaksın çocuk yapmadan bir evlilik
Olmaz böyle bir mantık yok mu beynimizin
zihninizin içinde çocuk yoksa bir
sıkıntı var demektir yani böyle
bakılıyor Bu da bizim geleneklerimiz ve
bu gelenekleri bizi ne yapıyor
gelenekleri bizi çocuk yapmaya nüfusu
arttırmaya teşvik ediyor Aslında din de
aynı şekilde çoğalın diyor bize
dinde söylemlerde bulunuyor Ve Din
nüfusu arttıran faktörlerden biri oluyor
demek göçler ama gelen göçler bazı
ülkeler göç alırlar Almanya gibi ülkeler
göç alır göç aldıkları içinde bu da
nüfusun artmasına neden olur orada Tabi
bazı ülkeler göç verir o da nüfusun
azalmasına neden olur tamam nüfusu
arttıran faktörleri öğrendik ama
yorumlamaya bilmen lazım nüfusu
arttırdık bu Nüfus artışının bazı olumlu
sonuç bazı ol
umsuzu arttırdım Ben bunun
olumlusunlayalım Ne Olur türkiye'deyiz
nüfus arttı daha çok mal ve hizmete daha
çok talep olur değil mi bu olumlu bir
şeydir yani ürettiğinizi üretim artar
üretim artar Yani sürekli bir üretime
olur Çünkü bal ve hizmetleri sürekli bir
talep var Yeniden üret sürekli üret olur
sürekli sende ülke olarak üretirsin
üretim artmış olur mal ve hizmetleri
sürekli bir talep olmuş olur ve bunun
sonucunda vergi gelirleri de artar bunu
en güzel örneği olarak ülkemizde mesela
ülkemizde son zamanlarda Hani mülteciler
geldi mültecilerin ülkemize gelmesi
nüfuslu ne yaptı arttırdı işte onun
üzerinden yorumlayalım bunu
bunun anlamış olabilir hocam ha mal ve
hizmetlere talep arttı ülkemizde
ülkemizde bir üretim mecburen artmak
zorunda kaldı artık devlet daha çok
dergi almaya başladı Çünkü daha çok
insan var daha çok insan tüketiyor daha
çok insan üretime katılmak zorunda
kalıyor üretim daha da artmış oluyor ve
bunun sonucunda devlet vergi gelirlerine
arttırmış oluyor demek ki ülkemizde
mültecilerin gelmesi bu gibi olumlu
sonuçlara neden olur Bunun dışında iş
gücü maliyeti azalmış ülkelerinizde
mültecilerin gelmesi işgücü maliyetini
düşürmüş bu olumlu bir şey kim için
bizim için değil ülkede yaşayan insanlar
için değil kimin için olumlu devlet için
olumlu devlet ya da Fabrikalar için ülke
için olumlu olmuş oluyor Yani devlet
için olumlu olunca Fabrikalar için
olumlu olmuş olunca ülke için olumlu
olmuş oluyor buradaki olumluluk mantığı
devlet bakış açısından Yoksa iş gücü
maliyeti ucuzlarsa bu bizim için
çalışanlar için ülkede yaşayanlar için
kötü bir şey ama devlet açısından
yorumlayacaksın Bunu devlet için iş gücü
maliyetinin azalması olumlu bir şey Adam
diyor ki 10 bin liraya çalıştı ama 5000
liraya çalıştırabiliyorum Bu da devlet
için işverenler için olumlu bir şey
oluşturdu mu oluşturdu Tabii ki bu Nüfus
artışının böyle olumsuz bunlar olumlu
yanlarıydı devlet için vesaire ülkemizde
böyle bir Nüfus artışı yaşanmasını Bir
de olumsuz yanlarında var ama bakalım
Mesela ülkemizdeki mülteci sayısının
artmasının olumsuz yanları da nelermiş 1
kişi başına düşen milli gelir azalır
Çünkü ülke parası önceden daha az kişiye
bölünecekken 80 milyona bölünecekken
şimdi 90 milyona bölünüyor gibi düşünün
bunu bu da kişi başına düşen milli
geliri azaltacaktır ne olacak eğitim şu
an yaşadığımız problemlerden biri bu
değil mi eğitim imkanlarına eğitimde
Tabi bu çok fazla görülmüyor ama sağlık
imkanlarına ulaşmamız daha zorlaşıyor
yetersiz kalabiliyor sağlık kuruluşları
Bakın bu nüfusun artmasının olumsuz
sonuçlarından birisini yaşıyoruz bakın
yaşayarak görüyorsunuz Aslında
yorumlayabilirsiniz ne oluyor işsizlik
artıyor nüfus arttı çalışacak bir sürü
kişi geldi o zaman işsizlikte artmış
oldu bakın tasarruflar azalıyor devletin
tasarrufları azalıyor daha fazla yatırım
yapmak zorunda kalıyor nüfus diyor çünkü
sürekli hizmet gerektiriyor Bunlar
diğeri yaşıyoruz suç oranları artıyor
Çünkü bir kalabalıklaşma gerçekleşiyor
ve bu da suç oranlarının artmasına neden
oluyor bu kalabalık çevresel sorunların
daha da fazla artmasına neden oluyor bu
kalabalık Tabii ki üretimi artırıyor
Tabii ki talebi arttırıyor ama aynı
zamanda Doğal kaynaklarımızın daha hızlı
tüketilmesine neden oluyor bu kalabalık
tam Az önce söylediğimiz tasarruflar
azalıyor ve demografik yatırımların
artmasına neden oluyor Demografik
yatırım ne bu en fazla çıkacak şeylerden
ve Kafanı karıştıracak yorumlardan bir
tanesi Demografik yatırım demografi
nüfus nüfusa yatırım yani hastane okul
yapmak zorunda kalıyoruz neden nüfusu
artıyor nüfusu artınca daha çok hastane
yapmak zorunda kalıyorsun ve bu da senin
ne oldu ya ve bu da senin demografik
yatırımların artmasına neden oluyor Yani
aynı zamanda tasarruflarında azalmasına
neden oluyor şimdi ne yaptık
nüfusu arttırırsak neler yaşarız bunu
söyledik ya da nüfusu neler arttırır
bunu konuştuk şimdi nüfusu neler azaltır
buna bakalım bir savaşlar ne yapar
Allah aşkı Suriye'de azaldı diğeri doğal
afetler doğal afet yaşandığında
nüfuslarda azalıyor değil mi nüfusta bir
azalma gerçekleşebiliyor Şurayı
yorumlamak zordur savaşın doğal afetin
nüfusu azaltacağını bilirsin şu önemli
burada kadının iş hayatına atılması Eğer
kadın İş hayatına atılırsa nüfus
azalacaktır Çünkü iş işte çalışan
kadınlar daha fazla çocuğa bakamaz bunu
bir çocukla iki çocukla ya da hiç çocuk
yapmayarak sınırlandırmak zorunda kalır
yani Normalde evde olsa belki 3 tane
yapacakken bakamayacağı için işe gidiyor
çünkü bir tane iki tane yapar kadını iş
hayatına atılması nüfusunu ne yapar o
zaman nüfus artış hızını azaltacaktır
giden göçler ülkeden giden göçler nüfus
artış nüfusu azaltacak ülkede eğitim
seviyesinin artmasını yorumlaman lazım
insanların eğitim seviyesi artarsa daha
az çocuk yapar çünkü insan düşünüyor o
zaman yani öylesine çocuk yapmıyor ben
buna bakabilir miyim diye düşünüyor ve
bununla bakamayacağını bildiği zaman
ekonomisi kötü olduğunda eğitim seviyesi
arttığın eğitim seviyesi arttığında
çocuk yapma oranında da azalıyor gençler
ve ülkelerin izlediği nüfus azaltıcı
politikalar gelişmemiş ülkeler Yani az
gelişmiş ülkeler Somali gibi ülkeler
Hindistan gibi ülkeler az gelişmiş
ülkeler Endonezya gibi ülkeler mesela
nüfusunu azaltıcı yönde politika
izliyorlar Tamam hocam
nüfusu bunun bize kötü sonuçları olur mu
yani mülteciler üzerinden konuştuk bu
durumu ülkeye mülteciler geldi dedik
bunun olumlu olumsuz sonuçlarını
konuştuk şöyle bir varsayımda bulunalım
ülkemizdeki mültecilerin tekrar
ülkelerindeki savaşın bittiğini
düşünelim ve kendi ülkelerine geri
döndüğünü düşünelim Bu da bizim
ülkemizdeki nüfusun azalmasına neden
olacak değil mi bunun Peki hocam olumlu
sonuçları olur mu bu bize bu insanlar
gittiğinde olur bir kişi başına düşen
milli gelirimiz artacaktır Yani bir
ülkede nüfuz azaldığında kişi başına
düşen milli gelir artacak artık
doğallıktan daha rahat yararlanmaya
başlayacağız eğitim kalitemiz daha da
fazla artacaktır tabii eğitime çok fazla
katıldıklarını düşünmüyorum burada değil
de daha çok mesela sağlıkta sağlık
imkanlarından daha rahat
yararlanabiliriz büyük bir ihtimalle
ülkemiz daha çok yatırım yapabilir
elimizde para birikmiş olur bunları
olumlu yanları olur bizim
için eğer azalırsa bizim gittiklerini ya
da kendi ülkemizde nüfusunda azaldığında
varsayarsak yaşlı nüfusumuz artacak Biz
yaşlı nüfus artış gösterecek Biz nüfus
hareketliliğini kaybedecek dinamizmini
kaybetmeye başlayacak gençler nüfusu
artış hızımız azalırsa Biz yaşlanacak
ülkemiz emeklilere bakacak çalışanlar
azalmaya başlayacak tüketim azalmaya
başlayacak tüketim azaldığı için üretimi
de azalmasına neden olacak bu durum Ya
şu nüfus lideri artacak dedik ve öyle
bir yere gelecek ki bir gün gelecek
nüfusumuz nüfus artış hızımız bizim
düşük mültecileri de yolladığımızı
düşünelim nüfus artış hızımızın da düşük
bir şekilde devam ettiğini düşünelim
artmadığımızı düşünelim Bir süre sonra
aynı Almanya gibi göç almak zorunda
kalacağız Dışarıda çalışan kişiye
ihtiyaç duyacağımız için tabii biz bizim
ülkemiz için bu biraz uzak bir Gelecekte
olacak bir durum ama gelişmiş ülkeler bu
durumu yaşıyorlar Evet bunları yorumlama
noktasında yorumlamıştır zaten sizinle
şimdi dünya nüfusun tarihsel süreçteki
değişimini göreceğiz nüfusun
sıçramalarına bakacağız ama ondan önce
şu kavramı bilmen lazım nüfusun ikiye
katlanma süresi ne demek hocam şurada
iki tane ülke
verdik insan Pakistan az gelişmiş
ülkeler Bunlar burada nüfusun ikiye
katlama süresi nasıldır ya da bir
gelişmiş ülkede nüfusun ikiye katlama
süresi nasıl gelin bunu Örneklerle
açıklayalım size
nüfus mesela Afganistan afganistan’ın
nüfusunun 5 olduğunu varsayalım nüfusunu
ikiye katlaması demek ne demek 10 olması
demek değil mi
Peki asistan
nüfusu sonra mı katlar hemen katlar
değil mi Şöyle biraz daha yakın yazdı
şöyle nüfusunu ikiye katladı mı nüfusunu
ikiye katlama süresine bakın kısa kısa
değil mi yani Afganistan gibi az
gelişmiş ülkelerin nüfusunu ikiye
katlama
süresi nüfusunu hemen ikiye katlarlar
ama Almanya'ya örnek verelim biz size
şimdi burada Almanya Almanya'nın
nüfusunun yine 5 olduğunu düşünelim ona
katlayacağız nüfusu öyle hemen ona kat
yok çünkü nüfus o kadar fazla hızlı
artmıyor doğumlar az çok uzun yıllar
sonra nüfusun ikiye katlayacak nüfusunu
ikiye katlama süresine bakın nüfusunu
ikiye katlama süresi uzundur değil mi
yani gelişmiş ülkelerde nüfusu ikiye
katlama süresi uzunken Afganistan gibi
az gelişmiş ülkelerin nüfusu ikiye
katlama süresi kısadır yani kısadır
derken hemen hızlı bir şekilde nüfusunu
İkiye Katlar demek istiyoruz buradaki
yorum mantığını da oturttuk bunu da
konuştuk geldik nüfusun sıçrama
dönemleri geçmiş tarihe baktığınızda
bütün dünyadaki
nüfusun tarihine baktığımızda geçmişte
nüfusu bazı dönemlerde böyle bir sıçrama
yaşadığını görüyoruz
bölüm tak bir sıçrama yaşadığını diyor
bize insanlara böyle yaşıyorlar Göçebe
böyle işte sağdan soldan avlanmaya
çalışıyorlar toplayıcılık elma yiyorlar
falan derken buradaki beslenme koşulları
çok kötü Belki çoğu zaman yemek
bulamadıkları için ölüp gidiyorlar ama
sonra nasıl aletler keşfediliyor alet
oksijen taşını öğrenmiştik ya sizinle
beraber Hani Can Volkan camı Game Of
thrones'ta vardı Böyle Obsidyen taşı
Game Of thrones'ta ejderha camı olarak
geçiyor Ve böyle nasıl biraz daha böyle
Keskin şuraya koyayım Hatta Bakın bu
Keskin bu keskinin bu taşın Keskin
olduğunu keşfediyor insanlar o dönemde
bunları böyle ne yapıyorlar
keskinleştirip bir çubuğun ucuna
bağlıyorlar Alın size mızrak yaptı onu
bıçak olarak kullanabiliyorlar bu alet
yapımı ile beraber artık
avlanabiliyorlar kendilerini
koruyabiliyorlar Bunlar beslenmelerini
daha da ileri seviye taşımasına neden
oluyor kendilerini korudukları için daha
az ölüyorlar ve böylece o dönemde nüfus
Bir tık sıçrama yaşıyor sonra
iki evrimi ile beraber
yine hala iyi değil tarımı keşfediyorum
tarımı keşfettikten sonra beslenme
koşullarım çok hızlı bir şekilde artıyor
beslenmem çok iyi bir şekle geldiği için
ben o kadar artık beslenmem benim
beslenmem iyileştiği için nüfus ne
olacak otomatik olarak bir sıçrama
dönemi yaşamış olacak bakın alet yapımı
sonra tarımın keşfedilmesiyle bir
sıçrama yaşıyoruz ama asıl sıçramayı
sanayi devrimi ile beraber yaşıyoruz
Çünkü sanayi devrimi ile beraber seri
üretime geçiyoruz her alanda her şeyde
takır takır seri üretime geçiyoruz
sanayi devrimi ile beraber seri üretime
geçtikten sonra sağlık imkanları
iyileşmeye başlıyor Tıpkı iyileşiyor
Bilimsel faaliyetler daha da hızlanıyor
derken Bütün bunlar bizim yaşam
koşullarımızı arttırıyor ve sanayi
devrimi ile beraber çok ciddi bir
sıçramaya yaşıyoruz nüfusta ve öyle bir
sıçrama ki şuna bak şu grafiğe bakar
mısınız Bak buradan geliyor Geliyor
geliyor 1 milyara şurada ulaşıyoruz
derken
8 milyara kadar Şuradaki sıçrama
Şuradaki sıçramama bakın sana iyi
devrimi ile beraber yaşanıyor Peki hocam
Tamam
öğrendik dünyadaki sıçramaları öğrendik
dünyanın yapana kadar olan nüfusu gördük
sanayi devrimi vesaire
Peki projeksiyon bizi
bekliyor nasıl Bak şuraya bakın şimdi
geçmişten geliyoruz şöyle 1900'lü
yıllarda şuralarda sanayi devrimi
yaşandıktan sonra bakın
0.6'lardan iken artış 0.6 dan 1970'lere
şöyle geldiğimizde iki nokta birlere
fırlamış bu nüfus artış hızını
gösteriyor sildim Şu an nüfus artış hızı
düşmeye başlıyor bak Çünkü aynı zamanda
eğitim seviyesi de arttı dünyada sürekli
eğitim seviyesi de artıyor gençler nüfus
artış hızı bakın düşüyor Ama nüfus artış
hızı düşse de dikkat edin 2050 yıllara
gittiğimizde nüfus artış hızı yine
düşecek 2100'lü yıllara gittiğimizde
nüfus artış hızı yine düşecek Ama dikkat
edin şuraya nüfus miktarı hep artış
gösterecek Çünkü nüfus artış hızı
sıfırın altına düşmüyor nüfus artış hızı
önceden iki iken yine daha da aşağı
Lara hala artmaya dünyada devam ediyor
ama artış hızı biraz daha yavaşlıyor
bakın 2 yüzlü yıllarda 11 milyara
yaklaşacağız Evet bunu da öğrendik
nüfusun dağılışına geçiyoruz artık
arkadaşlar bugün nüfusu öğrendik nüfusla
alakalı test sorularını soru bankamız
çıktı biliyorsunuz kampa Eylülde olacak
Buradaki test sorularını nüfusun daha şu
kısmı işlemeden izlemiyorsun
çözmüyorsunuz tamam mı Yani şurada
Türkiye nüfusuna kadar işleyeceğiz nüfus
piramitlerinde o zaman oradaki testi
çözeceksiniz iki video sonra oradaki
teste bakacaksınız Yani ben söyleyeceğim
size Merak etmeyin Evet arkadaşlar Bugün
çok önemli bir konuyu öğrendik yorum
yapmayı öğrendik yorum yapabildiğinizi
düşünüyorum görüyorsunuz gençler Bir
sonraki derste görüşmek üzere